et en fait tu vois les Juifs arabout
noir c'est vraiment des gens comme nous
enfin Rachida Dati Harlem Désir Frédéric
Lefebvre ils ont pas la même couleur
mais ils disent les mêmes conneries
et maintenant j'accueille Gaspard Proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
alors les actualités très bien France
polémique valse Duflot alors il paraît
que Hollande un recadrer féministe ça a
dû être un truc
dantesque au moment où il l'a fait dans
la savane la vie s'est arrêtée le
crocodile a lâché sa proie des papillons
sont tombés en torche
heureusement que la porte du Conseil des
ministres était bien fermé parce que
sinon le mec il déplaçait un fuseau
horaire
alors on reprend chez Hollande son
manque d'autorité ça c'est de la
perspicacité pure ça se voit sur son
physique tu l'imagines chaque Reiki avec
sa bouille de hamster sous MDMA
de toute façon il y a des signes qui te
trompent pas en ce moment il va
extrêmement mal quoi il a promis de
revenir tous les ans à Florange
avec son salaire il peut aller ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
mais je comprends que ce soit désolant
ce manque d'autorité enfin moi plus je
vois le manque d'autorité de Hollande en
France plus je me pose des questions sur
la force de caractère du peuple malien
Rome derrière toutes ces polémiques il y
a une question pourquoi est-ce qu'on
stigmatise les Roms mais la réponse est
simple parce que ça détend
bien
c'est le pied enfin c'est ça c'est le
principe du bouc émissaire c'est écrit
dans la Bible moi j'ai pas les moyens de
m'acheter un boucle de le pousser dehors
à chaque fois que j'ai un péché enfin je
veux dire je il y a le rhum il est là
maintenant
laissez-moi au moins ces gens là parce
que je veux pas prendre l'émission en
otage je suis pas là pour ça mais bon
moi quand je suis arrivé ici je
détestais tout le monde vraiment et puis
l'émission bon j'ai découvert qu'il y a
des Juifs qui travaillent ici
c'est dur de le dire mais en fait il y a
des mecs sympas
alors je me dis bon va pour les Juifs ok
je fais avec j'accepte alors je dis bon
il y a quelques Arabes là je me dis tu
vois alors je fais des chroniques très
anti halal et tout j'ai discuté avec
certains mais c'est des gens enfin comme
nous quoi
alors qu'est-ce que je fais en plus le
pire tu vois il y a des Noirs à
l'émission là je me dis je vais pas me
faire avoir tu te souviens quand je suis
venu ici je bon j'ai rapporté à tous un
petit peu de [ __ ] avec le truc
et en fait c'est dur est-ce que c'est
vrai qu'ils ont pas que le rythme dans
la peau ramasse
ils ont une conversation quoi
et
moi je me rends compte que quand tu
connais un peu les gens c'est vachement
dur d'être raciste
alors moi c'est bon en plus ça a été
très dur je dis les Africains en général
c'est très dur pour moi de pardonner
avec tout ce qui nous ont fait enfin la
décolonisation moi je m'en suis jamais
remis
moi j'oublie pas que si l'Algérie était
toujours française le prix du gasoil
serait un peu moins élevé
et j'ai
réfléchi quoi je me suis vraiment ouvert
comme une fleur de lotus qui
[Rires]
et en fait tu vois c'est vraiment des
gens comme nous enfin Rachida Dati
Harlem Désir Frédéric Lefèvre ils ont
pas la même couleur mais ils disent les
mêmes conneries tu vois
[Applaudissements]
monsieur on peut pas être tout le temps
dans l'amour on ne peut pas tout le
temps dans l'amour Jésus il est mort à
33 ans Le Pen il est toujours là
sujet suivant horaires des magasins
alors résumé si j'ai bien compris on va
fermer les magasins dimanche et en
semaine on va réduire les horaires c'est
vraiment une idée géniale c'est
tellement plus agréable de faire les
courses quand tout le monde est là tu
sais
je pense que l'objectif c'est de créer
des files d'attente devant les magasins
et big up l'URSS tu sais
quand tu vois les enjeux des municipales
c'est vraiment la bougeotte des rhums le
stress des mioches la frustration des
bricoleurs du dimanche ça va être quoi
le prochain sujet de polémique le taux
de sucre dans les chouquettes
oui parce que il y a aussi ce truc sur
les rythmes scolaires alors c'est la
zumba des élèves quoi faut dire alors
selon les médecins il faut que quatre
jours et demi ça c'est le bon rythme
c'est bon c'est des foutaises on va pas
assez loin l'avenir appartient aux gens
flexibles les gamins faut les habituer à
nouveau tes perpétuel c'est pendant une
semaine tu fais quatre jours et demi
semaine suivante 5 jours et demi puis 7
tu les réveils à 4h du matin surprise
[Applaudissements]
semaine prochaine Classe neige et boum
tu les amène au Sahel faire du ski tu
vois
pas de toute façon l'état il est sadique
il veut faire des rythmes scolaires il
interdit la vente des boissons
énergisantes aux jeunes
Français faut pas trop les exciter déjà
qu'ils ont Jean-Marc Hérault pour modèle
doucement une chose après l'autre quoi
parce que sinon et puis une fois que
l'école est finie maintenant on promet
une récompense espèce de RSA jeune un
truc pour les 18-25 ans bon pourquoi pas
non mais moi je me suis renseigne le RSA
est jeune va s'adresser aux jeunes qui
n'ont même pas accès à un emploi
d'avenir
c'est pas pour toi
en fait on va te donner directement une
subvention parce que
c'est ça ou alors une ordonnance pour du
cyanure vraiment on choisit quoi
ça j'ai vu que dès 2017 un jeune sur
trois sera financé par l'État donc par
les contribuables ouais en fait on vient
d'inventer la pension alimentaire pour
les gens qui n'ont pas d'enfants
[ __ ] c'est engagé j'arrête trésorerie
le PS déclare 60 millions de recettes
c'est pas des chiffres définitifs on
attend encore que le fils Fabius rentre
de Deauville
international IALTA sous le patronage de
Poutine et la bienveillance d'Obama
Beyrou a rencontré Bordeaux
en tout cas à Bordeaux qui se rapproche
de Beyrout c'est Vesoul qui dit à
Commercy vient
alors terminé par une bonne nouvelle
l'affiche du film Diana a été retirée du
pont de l'Alma
non mais ça allait trop loin en même
temps pour une fois qu'on pouvait
rappeler aux Français que les voitures
allemandes ne sont pas aussi fiables
qu'on le dit
alors
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu